Black Adam is a menacing figure not afraid
to kill to deliver his brand of justice.
But how does Dwayne Johnson compare
to his alter ego as the DC anti-hero?
The newest DC Extended Universe film, "Black
Adam," was just released to theaters last week
on October 21, 2022. Directed by Jaume
Collet-Serra, the film stars Dwayne "The
Rock" Johnson as the titular Black Adam, a former
slave from Kahndaq who possesses the same powers
as a similar character, Shazam. They include
gifts like super strength and speed, as well
as more psychological powers such as courage
and wisdom. After being imprisoned for nearly
5,000 years, Black Adam finally escapes
and is ready to bring justice to the world.
"You can be the destroyer of this
world, or you can be its savior."
While Johnson leads the pack, the film also
boasts an impressive list of supporting cast
members. This includes Pierce Brosnan
as Doctor Fate, a senior member of the
Justice Society of America; Aldis
Hodge as Hawkman, the JSA leader;
Noah Centineo as Atom Smasher, a young JSA
member who can control his size and strength;
and Quintessa Swindell as Cyclone, a JSA
member who can control wind and sound. Then
there is Marwan Kenzari as Sabbac, the militant
leader of the criminal organization Intergang,
and Sarah Shahi as professor and resistance
fighter Adrianna Tomaz, an ally to the JSA.
In a September 2022 interview with Vanity
Fair, Noah Centineo discussed "Black Adam"
and opened up about working with Dwayne
Johnson for the film. Centineo, for one,
had nothing but praise for Johnson as an
actor, co-star, and role model. Centineo said,
"Dwayne [Johnson] is 99 percent more present than
most people. They say don't meet
your idols — not true with Dwayne."
Centineo also noted that working on "Black
Adam" acted as a learning experience for him,
as well, thanks in part to Johnson, saying,
"Pierce Brosnan is to the right, The Rock
is to the left. I'm getting a master class."
The actor then spoke again about
working with Johnson in an October
2022 interview with Pinkvilla alongside
his co-star Quintessa Swindell. Both
stars had nothing but praise for Johnson.
Swindell began by noting that he is funnier
than they expected and made everyone
laugh on set constantly, then added,
"Also, just to work with and be around and
to learn from. And he's incredibly giving."
Centineo added that one of
the first things he noticed,
which Swindell wholeheartedly agreed
with, is that Johnson's social media
presence matches up to what he's
like in real life. Centineo said,
"So, I feel like he's very honest
about who he is, which is tight."
Back in August 2021, Pierce Brosnan was already
beginning to publicly praise Dwayne Johnson
for his work in "Black Adam" while speaking
with Haute Living for an interview. Brosnan
was filming "Black Adam" at the time of the
interview, so his opinions on his co-star
were fresh. Brosnan noted that, due to the
nature of the film, he didn't spend a ton of
time on set working with Johnson but that he
has respect for his co-star overall. He said,
"As for Dwayne, I don't know the man,
but I've got great admiration for him
and what he's created for himself in life
and how he conducts himself with the world
at large. So we go to set and get on with
the work, and that's what you have to do."
Brosnan then praised Johnson again a month
later while speaking to Collider in September
2021 to promote 2021's "Cinderella."
Brosnan gave fans some early insight
into what to expect from Johnson's superhero
performance. The former James Bond actor said,
"It's an ensemble piece, 'Black Adam.'
You have Dwayne, who's at the pinnacle
of his fame and fortune and success and
popularity. He is magnificent as Black Adam."